افدى مراسلنا باصابه فلسطيني بجروح نحرج
برصاص قوات الاحتلال عند باب السلسله في
البلده القديمه بالقدس المحتله هذا وافادت
مصادر بان قوات الاحتلال دفعت بتعزيزات
عسكريه مشدده داخل البلده القديمه واغلقت
عددا من الابواب المؤديه الى المسجد
الاقصى واعتدت ايضا على عدد من المعتكفين
داخل المسجد
معنى من القدس مراسل الجزيره احمد هزيم
احمد اهلا بك اذا كيف يتطور الوضع في
البلده القديمه تحديدا
سفيان تطورات الوضع كما ذكرت هي عمليه
اطلاق نار على شاب حسب شهود عيان هو احد
حراس المسجد الاقصى وانه حاول الدفاع عن
سيده فلسطينيه اعتدى عليها جنون من قوات
الاحتلال ما دفع بها الجنود الى اطلاق
النار عليه واصابته اصابات بالغه ومن ثم
اغلاق عدد من الابواب
والاقتحام اباحات البلده القديمه
والاشتباك مع التجار الفلسطينيين كما
اظهرت صور وتسجيلات نشرت على وسائل
التواصل والتواصل الاجتماعي عفوا سفيان
وهذا كله حسب شهود عيان كانوا حاضرين في
اثناء عمليه الاقتحام واثناء عمليه اطلاق
النار هناك ردود فعل فلسطينيه سفيان
المتحدث باسم حركه نتحدث عندما يحدث في
على الشباب والاعتداء على المصلين كحسب
قوله هو استفزاز للمرابطين تمهيدا للسماع
المستوطنين بالاقتحامات وممارسه طقوس
التلموديه حسب قوله ادانه عيد الفطر
اليهودي هناك ايضا ردود فعل من قبل حركه
حماس التي دعت لا في بيان الله بيان مقتضب
الى
الصمود في القدس وان فعلت القوات الاحتلال
هذه الليله من اعتداء على هذا الشاب
الفلسطيني هو جزء حسب قوله حماس من الحرب
الدينيه التي يشدها الاحتلال على القدس
واهالي
طيب يبدو ان الخط انقطع نشكرك اذا نحمل
هزيم شكرا لك